it is my pleasure to welcome everyone to
this world leaders forum event featuring
President Nicolas Sarkozy of France I
want to acknowledge our co-sponsors
especially the maison France A's which
played a critical role in making today's
event possible
as well as the Colombia Paris alliance
program I also offer special thanks to
the Consulate General of France in New
York for helping to arrange this event
but also like this very special welcome
to first lady Carlos Sarkozy do please
stand so that we can welcome you
also like again to extend a very special
welcome to christine lagarde
france's Minister of Economic Affairs
industry and employment
I also like to acknowledge my wife
Jeanne mignon Oh Bollinger who's here
today is one of the highlights of the
world leaders forum series which has
become one of the nation's leading
venues for prominent and influential
people to address critical issues of our
time since 2003 this year-round program
has featured heads of state from every
continent the resulting range of
perspectives and the spectrum of topics
discussed in the forum have enriched the
already wide diversity of perspectives
that characterize this great academic
institution at times the forum has
sparked meaningful discussion and debate
here and around the world which must be
expected and welcome to arise from a
fundamental commitment to vigorous
freedom of speech the only position the
university holds and it holds it
strongly today we are honored to have
president Sarkozy the sixth president of
the Fifth Republic of France president
Sarkozy came to the presidency after
extensive public service including
nearly two decades as the mayor of a
Paris suburb as well as cabinet roles in
the national government as both Minister
of the Interior and Minister of Finance
he holds degrees in political science
and law and he is the author of
testimony France in the 21st century
published in 2007 President Sarkozy
holds a very special place in
contemporary political culture the
France of Europe and the world is both
vigorous and visible outspoken and
intent on action in following him one
has the sense that he is more inclined
than most to express his views as they
are and without regard to the political
consequences that might follow surely
that makes them a delight to us
those of us who inhabit the halls of the
Academy I cannot say what others might
think I do since he is unafraid of
controversy which is good since his
disposition seems likely to generate a
lot of it president Sarkozy is to be
sure praised by critics and supporters
alike for his oratory skill his charisma
and his determined leadership president
Sarkozy visit to Colombia allows us to
celebrate two important relationships
that of Colombia with France and the
French language and culture and that of
the United States with France and the
French people today there are about two
hundred students from France enrolled at
Columbia and many of Columbia's students
study in France especially at our
historic site in Paris known as Reed
Hall which we just two weeks ago
launched as our global center for Europe
part of our system of centers around the
world designed to facilitate research
and teaching on globalization the
Columbia Paris Paris Alliance program
has flourished since it was founded in
2002 with our distinguished partners
Ecole Polytechnique science po and Paris
one already more than 200 students have
benefitted from dual and joint degree
programs under the Alliance Columbia's
mailmen School of Public Health the
School of Art the School of
International Public Affairs the
European Institute the Institute of
African Studies and many others have
very active programs in or involved with
france and francophone studies crowning
all of these activities at Columbia's
the famous Mazal and Frances and the
Department of French the top academic
department in the United States in many
respects Columbia is a symbol for the
historically strong relationship between
the United States and France thousands
of our citizens work in French companies
in France and just as thousands of
French citizens live and work in this
country for US companies as the world's
fifth largest economy as a leader of
Europe
as the source of ideals to which we and
so many others have staked our
collective lives and as the partner of
the United States and nearly every
international policy not least not least
now in Afghanistan we have much to
celebrate in the connections between our
respective countries mr. president we
are very much aware that you have come
to Colombia in order to deliver a major
address while visiting our country we
are pleased and proud to welcome you we
also know that you come here at a moment
of great uncertainty and even crisis in
world affairs the fragile economy of the
fragile recovery from a near global
financial collapse begs for solutions
beyond nations voluntarily moving in
concert almost always a remedy unlikely
to succeed the long-term disaster of
climate change poses the initiative the
additional dilemma of how to overcome
the human tendency to shortsightedness
meanwhile extremism and its propensity
to violence plague our opportunities to
build better lives for everyone yet
unjust inequality and marginalization of
populations remain our responsibility to
remedy if we are to speak credibly about
the potential we see in our political
economic and social philosophies and for
all this we are in critical need of a
free and uninhibited flow of information
and ideas and yet we are experiencing a
rise in censorship around the globe that
threatens our capacity to see and think
clearly we are in short in desperate
need of strong global norms and
institutions to guide us successfully
through this new century a fresh
leadership on a scale that reordered the
world after World War Two mr. president
you have spoken to all of these issues
because of your important office we have
listened intently with admiration at
your fearless outspokenness and we will
do so again today
thank you for allowing Columbia to share
in your present visit to the United
States and when you dine tomorrow
evening alone with President Obama would
you please extend to him our very best
regards from his alma mater president
Sarkozy
hello should be challenge is not to read
a speech because speeches kill off
creativity if one comes simply to read a
speech well one might as well send the
speech ahead of time and save time and
carbon on the travel now I'm going to
speak from the heart as a friend which
doesn't mean that we all agree on
everything I say and through you I am
addressing the great people of the
United States so that you should
understand that Europe and the United
States of America must must work
together in Europe we are your friends
your European friends we in Europe
admire you you need not worry about that
however in Europe what we want is to be
heard to be listened to by the United
States of America that we should put our
heads together and think together you
belong to a country that is the world's
number one power with the strongest
currency the strongest economy and the
largest army
and you have to think about this very
carefully because what does that mean to
be the world's number one power the
world's number one power leading power
must precisely be that a leader but the
world's number one power must also
consider that because it is powerful
that it must share it must listen it
must discuss it must exchange ideas and
views with others we are now fully in
the 21st century there is not a single
country anywhere on this planet which in
the 21st century can run the world
single-handedly in the 20th century that
was still possible at the end of the
Second World War one could imagine a
single world power but in the 21st
century we must all of us understand
that in order to rule the world to
govern the world rather which is now a
multipolar world one has to accept that
strength and power means dialogue it is
because you are strong that you can
enter into dialogue in the history of
the world it is only the weak who have
turned our backs on dialogue now this is
a sea change from that point of view
moving from the 20th to the 21st century
any single nation however powerful
however strong cannot impose its views
upon the rest of the world now there's a
second thing of which I am totally
certain and that is that in the 21st
century we must come up with new answers
and these new answers
it is we the leaders the heads of state
and government of today and you the
leaders of tomorrow who have to design
them come up with them and from that
point of view the crisis that has shaken
us 18 months ago a forces extraordinary
opportunities many many things have to
be redesigned rethought through and the
third idea I wish to share with you is
that if Europe in the United States of
America do not redesign this new model
then no one else will do it in you of us
that is something you really have to
understand alone a Europe will not be
able to impose its ideas standing alone
the United States America will not be
able to do so either but if we together
do not come up with new fresh ideas then
no one else will do it instead of us and
that is the reason why I'm here that I
have come to the States and that is the
reason that has governed all my
political choices since I was elected
president of the French Republic I have
wished I have wanted France to return
fully into the fold of me - why did I
want that I wanted that because I wanted
a frank open dialogue with no
afterthoughts
with no hidden agenda with the United
States for as long as France wasn't
fully within the fold of NATO when
France said something there was always
the suspicion the was something that
wasn't entirely right in the
franco-american relationship now we're
back fully in the fold of NATO we are
your allies you have nothing to fear
from that point of view nothing the only
thing that I requested of your President
President Obama
was that we could have a totally open
free discussion let me give her some
examples of this when we were hit by the
economic crisis and that the American
administration simply walked away from
Lehman Brothers what you have to realize
is that the knock-on effect was not only
felt in the United States but the
knock-on effect was disastrous elsewhere
in the world everywhere else in the
world now to say this is not to make
it's not to criticize it's not to be
reproachful it is simply to call a spade
a spade the world is totally fully
interdependent and interlocked what you
succeed in doing here will be a success
for the rest of the world what you fail
to do here will be a failure for the
rest of the world this means that we
have joint shared responsibility now
having said that what can we do together
we admire the American economic model we
admire your corporations your companies
we admire your universities in fact I
called for a reform of French University
and the French university system much in
keeping with what you are familiar with
here with the the fact the only thing is
it's not free paying that's the
difference but economic world economic
regulation can no longer stand still
they can't stay where it is we can no
longer accept as capitalist system where
there are no rules no organization no
structure no regulation no I know that
when a Frenchman comes here he's always
a suspect in some way
isn't he really talking about
protectionism perhaps isn't he a bit of
a socialist is he enough is he free
trade enough well let me say one thing
by calling for the regulation of
capitalism what I am doing is laying the
foundations of that which will save
capitalism market economy and unbridled
capitalism is tantamount to the death of
capitalism because one day people will
no longer accept what occurred 18 months
ago reoccurring let me explain this what
Americans should learn a lot of money
that some Europeans should earn a lot of
money that's all well and good it's only
right and proper however you can't win
everywhere and on every front you can't
have the bonuses one day and to say no
clawback if there's a problem when the
crisis fell upon us I asked my own team
my advisers couldn't we have some kind
of clawback system in order to sanction
all those who brought us to the brink of
this disaster and they said to me that's
impossible it's impossible to pinpoint
who is responsible I said oh very well
so produce me a list of those who were
given bonuses when things were all fine
and dandy last year
I'm slap a clawback on them system we no
longer want a system when when all is
well everyone's prepared to endorse
responsibility and when things are going
badly there's no one inside do you get
me here the market economy mean
responsibility you can't have people
responsible when things are going well
and you're earning more and no one
responsible when things are going badly
and you're earning less and I would like
to pay tribute
courage the boldness of President Obama
because at the London g20 summit we
wanted to put an end to the tax havens
you the younger generation has to have
to understand what is the point of
giving ourselves rules for our society
when you can simply transfer a
subsidiary to a tax haven and simply
circumvent the rules who can understand
that now there are hundreds of thousands
possibly millions of Americans who have
lost their homes who have lost their
jobs as a result of this crisis they had
nothing to do with it wasn't their fault
and yet they are left high and dry is
this is this right and proper in Europe
in all our economies unemployment is on
the up and up the French Minister of the
economy the French French Minister the
economy is here what can we tell the
unemployed who have new responsibilities
in this whose fault it is not and who
see that the world economy was shaken to
its roots simply because a few hundred
totally irresponsible hotheads did mer
things on the stock market with
derivatives and with other people's
money do you think we can defend
capitalism the market economy free trade
when there's so much injustice I don't
think so because it is impossible to
defend now tomorrow I will be seeing
President Obama
what am I going to be talking about with
him what are we going to talk about
together one thing principally and
primarily how can together how together
can we ensure that what occurred 18
months ago should never reoccur that is
our only responsibility 18 months ago
when it happened
we were almost swept away by this tidal
wave everything was virtually knocked
down and when I see that today the
self-same people are prepared to start
all over again committing the same
mistakes I do not want to be an
accomplice to aid and abet that do you
will get me there
is that clear I don't want it and I will
not do it because the next crisis we the
state nation states are so heavily
undated that we will no longer be able
to set up the ramparts the fortresses to
avoid catastrophe occurring what I want
you to understand is that Europe and the
United States of America together can
redesign design the rules to stabilize
the world economy it's not a matter of
moving from total absence of regulation
to excess regulation it is simply a
matter of regulating the market economy
on a worldwide scale that's all and from
that point of view if Europe can be
backed by the United States then we will
win if Europe and in the United States
are in confrontation on this then we
will lose both of us together
it is Europe and the United States of
America that together can redesign
invent the new world economy now another
example second example I'd like to share
with you commodities oil prices is it
right that in the space of less than two
years oil prices should have moved from
30 Durrell's
dollars a barrel of bread to 150 dollars
it's too expensive the next day it's not
expensive enough would it not be in our
interest
economies that are consuming fossil
fuels and those countries that are
producing oil to lay down the basis of
rules whereby we could have a barrel
price let's say $80 would that not be in
the interest of one and all when the
barrel of oil was too highly priced we
would go to see the producer countries
it's much too expensive but when oil
prices crashed we were rubbing our hands
with lead that is not responsible that
is not responsible behavior I'm talking
about oil I could not talk about gas I
could talk about all commodities for
that matter we have to regulate the
world economy it is our responsibility
to do so Third Point in the room we have
with us professor Stiglitz
a man from whom I have much admiration
and a nobel economic Lauria and together
we stopped early to see I entrusted them
with the task of setting up a think-tank
in order to invent and this is of
interest to you directly you students to
come up with new criteria to gauge
growth and measure growth if together we
still stick to criteria to measure
growth exclusively in quantitative terms
then we will not be able to achieve
sustainable growth we have to gauge the
way our economies grow differently
because we're in the 21st century which
is a very different sort of century to
the 19th century what we have to gauge
and measure is well-being education the
cost of our in my environment these are
criteria that we have to weave in to the
way we measure engage our economies if
we measure our economy exclusively in
quantitative terms and with quantitative
criteria then we will be incapable of
availing ourselves of a quality economy
worldwide and there again we have to
show breadth of imagination we have to
understand things a last example a
market economy is a production economy
that creates value over the past 20
years the world economy has become a
speculation economy we have committed to
a production economy not a speculative
economy that's a an inventor a designer
someone like Bill Gates should earn a
lot of money because he's come up with
new concepts new ideas and that he made
new discoveries he broke new ground and
he gave has given jobs to tens of
thousands of people worldwide is only
right and proper it is only right and
proper that that should be the case but
people should earn money on speculation
because they're basically speculating on
whether the new york stock exchange is
going to go from five to six thousand
base points it's not a system in which I
wish to live and if we live in a system
where we are not living in a caricature
of the market economy and capitalism we
will in fact be saving capitalism in the
market economy and in order for us to be
successful in this the great American
people have to understand that an
absence of rule and regulation kills off
freedom that freedom feeds on a minimum
of rules and regulations it enables us
to do things that other situations would
not allow us
to do if the great people of America
understand this and throw their weight
into the battle to come up with new
standards new norms and regulations then
the world will avail itself of balanced
rules another tremendous area where we
when we need to work together is new
world governance I was in Copenhagen for
the environment the world environment
summit and this afternoon I will be
meeting with the secretary-general of
the UN now Copenhagen was almost the
caricature of the failure of a certain
sort of way of going about things how
does it work we have a UN Security
Council with a certain number of
permanent members who have a right of
veto the Security Council and its
membership was decided just at the end
of the Second World War do you know that
you young students Columbia University
you know that there isn't a single
African country that is that has a
permanent seat on the UN Security
Council 1 billion in happens inhabitants
were talking about here did you know
that there isn't a single Arab country
who represent hundreds of millions of
people who has a permanent seat on the
UN Security Council did you know that
India that is 1 billion inhabitants in
30 years time the world's most populous
nation that doesn't have a permanent
seat on the UN Security Council the
Japan the world's second most powerful
economy should not have a seat on the
Security Council why is that the case
quite simply because 60 years ago they
lost the war is that reasonable I ask
you did you know there isn't a single
country from Latin America
that has a permanent seat on the UN
Security Council how I mean honestly
honestly how can you expect us to
regulate within the UN framework and
deal with the major crisis the major
Wars the major conflicts if we are still
in a mindset whereby we think we can do
so without Africa without three-quarters
of Asia without Latin America without a
single Arab nation is that reasonable
does that make any kind of sense to you
is it even thinkable I mean who could
believe that
well then I'm told yes but but there's
the UN General Assembly they're all
members of that well all very well at
192 countries worldwide it's the G 192
so we move from a system the Security
Council where we want to sort things out
without two-thirds of mankind to a
system where they owned the last one the
last country of whatever country if
they're not happy can actually veto and
block everybody else well the United
States of America and Europe together
have to demand that world governance be
reformed in order to make room for the
continents and countries of tomorrow who
are entitled to have their views
listened to I mean how could you expect
Brazil or India or Africa for that
matter to endorse part of the
responsibility's visa via the world's
major difficulties in conflicts if
they're not even listen to would you
like to be in their shoes would you like
to be told well look you have to when it
comes to paying up step up but when it
comes to speaking up step down I mean
who can understand that who could go
along with that nobody and so together
with Gordon Brown we
we have tabled a temporary provisional
reform for world governance and the UN
Security Council as French president I
was a member of the g8 and I say well
the g8 mm-hmm so what it's difficult to
imagine that it actually represents much
because that's not China that's not
India there's not Mexico there's no
South Africa we invite them we invite
them at the end of the g8 summits for
lunch
we were inviting the five
representatives of 2.5 billion
inhabitants of the world to travel and
from across the world simply to have
lunch with us and we didn't even see we
didn't get it that one day it would be
that g5 that would refuse to invite the
g8 its table and not the g8 that would
refuse to invite the g5 but my dear
friends I don't say this because I'm an
advocate for Africa Latin America or
Asia although I'd be happy to do so but
I say this because if we don't I believe
we don't change world governance we
don't stand a chance of responding to
and a being able to manage tomorrow's
conflicts for Iran where we have to show
total firmness that must not be allowed
to get it it's hand on nuclear weapons
we have we need the support of China and
Russia in order to agree on sanctions so
everyone has to be on board the world
governance ship in order to take the
decisions collectively and not getting
wrong the alliance between the United
States America and Europe is of the
essence here lastly we are here in New
York a town Amata City in 9/11 2001 to
one has forgotten that and the fight
against terrorism
we all of us need to pull our weight you
need us and we need you when I woke up
this morning I heard that our Russian
friends because they are our friends
have been hit by two attacks in the
Moscow subway there's more than 30 dead
2 kamikaze women blew themselves up on
the subway do you think there's any
difference between the mad people who
were killing innocents in the Moscow
subway the crazed individuals who hit
the Twin Towers here in New York I mean
do we make a difference do we start
picking and choosing and have a kind of
ranking of terrorism no of course not
when New York was attacked it was the
world's democracies who were under
attack
and when Moscow is attacked it is all of
us who were attacked when faced with
terrorism and terrorism terrorists we
cannot stand divided when the American
president is in Afghanistan you know in
France
it's not easy to explain that French
troops are dying in Afghanistan but I
tell you this we will stay by your side
in Afghanistan because the fight against
terrorism is a fight that we are all of
us involved in not simply the Americans
all of us because I do not want the
Taliban to make office Afghanistan
suffer nor do I want the new nuclear
weapons to fall in the hands of
terrorism and terrorists therefore we
need to work together all of us and
lastly I will conclude before answering
your questions
I'm trying by sometimes trying to
imagine if I were a young American what
I would be thinking you know you have a
country which is a continent from east
to west east coast to west coast you
have succeed exceptionally in so many
areas you have your problems that you
must solve but truly truly believe you
me you must never turn your backs on the
rest of the world and look inwards the
world needs an open America a generous
America an America that shows the way
that is attune to the suffering and
expectations of others you are much
loved throughout the world but there are
many expectations of you and sometimes
when you are less loved it is because
our expectations were so great that we
had the sense that we were a little
disappointed when you chose President
Obama the entire world was proud of you
the entire world placed it its hopes in
you and I should say that the debate
between President Obama and Senator
McCain I felt was a triumph of American
democracy and sometimes when I speak to
President Obama
I have great pleasure in talking with
him discussing things with him sometimes
says to me you know on certain issues
such as the environmental regulation I'm
a little ahead of what a lot of
Americans believe and I say to him don't
lag and I say to you rather don't lag
behind your president when it comes to
regulation when it comes to defending
the environment when it comes to
listening to others because in this
world of ours the world of the 21st
century we cannot afford to have the
world's number one power not being open
to the rest of the world the world does
not stop at the East Coast nor at the
West Coast so there please take this
message from a French president who is
your true friend who admires you and who
loves the United States of America thank
you
if what they see was a vacant probably
nude now if you have a few minutes I'd
be happy to answer any questions you may
have you will see be as open in your
questions as I have been in what I've
said see that I don't fall in the
kitchen
mr. president thank you for allowing us
to ask you some questions and thank you
for being at this university according
to you what are the characteristics that
we need to develop in order to here in
universities the first thing we're going
to look at is your autonomous status
that is the most important for me a
university is a place of freedom the
wealth of universities is precisely
based on the freedom they're in the
freedom to choose your professors I mean
trailers here in Columbia you even have
French French professors Wow that just
goes to show how for you really are and
my dream is that there should be
American professors coming to France
without there being an uproar talking
about nationalism and protectionism and
heaven knows what else the research
programs in Columbia I looked it is your
board and your scientists that ladies
done it is not up to the state to define
the contents of research program now
what was Frances problem from that point
of view
it's I think we misunderstood the word
equality equality does not equate with
uniformity equality is tailored to the
merits or needs of each and everyone
what I like about the American model is
the way in which merit effort work
initiative audacity are rewarded that is
my first point my second point is that
there is you can't have a virtual campus
it cannot develop in a virtual manner
and I'm a bit fed up when I see that
places as magnificent as this only
exists in the United States I have in my
delegation some major French scientists
heads of big top ranking schools and
colleges and I believe that you cannot
work on tiny campuses with libraries
that are shut on Sundays in buildings
where whose beauty is considered to be
inversely proportional to its state of
decomposition I want to open up our
windows and our doors to creativity and
perhaps also to get our campuses
universities to compete with one another
and to reward those who do most and more
I also want American New American
students to be able to be welcomed into
our universities and that there should
be many French students coming over here
I mean what is the point of the 21st
century world in which we can travel
freely if you can't come and study in
our country and if we have difficulty in
sending students to yours that is
exactly what we are changing in France
right now now
change is always difficult you know
right it worries
it goes against habit but the duty of a
statesman is to pursue change when
change is necessary you know ultimately
I believe that when a politician is
elected to office
he's only actually trodden ten percent
of the road
many of the politicians who were my
predecessors thought that just by
getting elected they'd traveled the road
I believe that to be elected is simply
the first step down the road and that
the responsibility of politicians and
the heads of states such as ourselves is
to be like CEOs of companies in other
words we should be judged on results of
what we achieve and produce and that is
precisely what the university reform we
are undertaken in France is all about is
go ahead
the microphone please
the it's a French system of Health that
is considered the best in the world what
is the advice that you can give us to
improve the health system in the United
States what you want to be involved in
the American battleground as if I didn't
have enough battles to fight back home
why I will run away first of all I want
to congratulate President Obama and
having succeeded in getting his this
reform through whatever you whatever you
I you think of this reform the fact of
the matter is that he wanted this reform
and he got it and it's only right to
congratulate him on that if you want me
to be absolutely sincere upfront with
you sometimes seen from the European
perspective when we look at the American
debates on reforming health care it's
difficult to believe we rub our eyes in
disbelief the idea I mean the very fact
that it should have given rise to such
violent debate simply on the fact that
the poorest of American society should
not be left out in the streets without a
cent to look after them from the health
care point of view is something
astonishing to us I mean we saw it the
problem out 50 years ago of course it's
difficulty of course it's it's expensive
because health care is expensive but you
can't let people simply die government
can't simply turn its back on those who
don't have the means to go to hospitals
well I don't want to get too involved
but honestly if you come to France and
something happened to you I don't know
on the sidewalk we're not gonna be you
do have to ask for your credit card
before you're rushed to hospital
now what I want what I want is that in
the United States everyone should be
able to feel the same way in other words
that if they have lost
they've been dispersed dispossessed of
everything they've lost everything they
will not be left out in the street out
in the cold so yes I admire President
Obama for having done what he did
at the same time I have a huge amount of
respect for Senator McCain because I
felt that his behavior he he was very he
behaved magnificently you know by and
large anything that happens in the
United States is followed with keen
interest in France and it's right that
it that should be the case because it's
important that all of us in our country
should not be naval gazes that we should
look at what's going on elsewhere in
other people's countries I've said this
time it again we don't need to reinvent
everything I would like to get my
inspiration from what others have done
better than us I love my country I'm
proud of my country I represent my
country but when you get things wrong
when you barked up the wrong tree
then I don't hesitate to say let us look
at what others have done and let us draw
inspiration from that in order to apply
it to our own case that is also the
advantage of globalization you know so
welcome to the club of states who don't
turn their backs on the sick and the
poor mr. president how do you see the
role of Europe given the present
economic difficulties how do what way do
you see out of it well this has been one
hell of a debate
and took out a lot of my time with
Chancellor Merkel in particular
Chancellor Merkel I know that people
don't always understand how Europe works
and people get irritated with the way we
go about things but do you realize
Europe is 27 countries 27 member states
27 countries who for centuries we're at
each other's throats were a war with one
another hated one another between the
French and the German three wars between
the British and the French I would even
go down that one mine is in the French
so well between the Italians and the
French it's always been beautiful
beautiful relationship miss Pacala are
these 27 countries decided we all
decided collectively to make peace and
to walk in the same direction you know
it's very complicated to get all of that
to work but it worked now within the 27
the 16 countries 16 countries who
decided are you listening carefully that
we would have the same currency the same
currency when Greece came under attack
what a case I put to my colleagues was
not that it was Greece that was coming
under your the Euro our currency
therefore we had to show solidarity and
I drew a lot of inspiration from what
happened here with Lehman Brothers know
if we had turned our backs on Greece if
we had let Greece fail then the crisis
would have flared up again now with
Lehman Brothers I understand of the line
of reasoning mr. Paulson at the time why
gave taxpayers money in order to bail
out a bank that was badly run let us
simply walk away from them now when you
walked away from me
eleven brothers throughout the world
Ziva's said ah so this means a bank can
fail and go bankrupt whence the panic
that flared up worldwide which is why we
decided to step in and support Greece
and since we took that decision My dear
Christine Lagarde spreads interest rates
and speculation has calmed down
why because speculators are out there
like Toria doors for as long as you
don't actually build a wall a rampart
that prodding is testing us once you say
okay you're just provoking us here's the
money on the table I think back down
that's what solidarity means and that
solidarity is essential it's a sign
equine on and last time I spoke to
President Obama in other words last week
over the phone because we had a video
conference with a Gordon Brown
Chancellor Merkel President Obama and
myself about once a month mr. Obama said
to me what are you going to do about
Greece because he knew perfectly well
that you that stability in the u.s. to a
certain extent hinged on what we and the
eurozone would be capable or not of
doing that is today's world that is why
when the decision was taken not to bail
out Lehman Brothers we would quite like
to have been founded out at the time and
not simply told about it after the event
that is what solidarity and
interdependence means a last question
perhaps
well show me she lays it on you've made
the point that in the 21st century there
needs to be a greater level of economic
cooperation between all countries in the
world not just you know not just the
countries that are on the Security
Council but at places such as Japan and
Latin America don't have any real spots
there and that your voices are not being
heard you know you made the argument
that they you know in the case of Japan
they lost the world it could also be
said that Africa and Latin America are
not being listened to for the simple
reason that in recent history they work
holidays if the developing world is to
have its voice heard in this new
cooperation what sort of framework do
you envision for that become become in
the case
oh poor one deceased well I mean it's a
simple system every part every region of
the world must have two to three
representatives on the UN Security
Council on a permanent basis and every
region of the world should be able to
German freely the basis on which they
choose their two or three
representatives there again the world
doesn't need uniformity let me take the
example of Latin America Brazil should I
be Argentina should they elect their
representatives to a permanent seat it's
up to them to decide we the
international community should say look
what what we want as permanent members
of the Security Council one or two
people representing Latin American
choose them as you will it can be by our
elections it can be on a rotating basis
it can be a huge country like Brazil I
mean how can you imagine running the
affairs of the world without the
Brazilian giant sitting at the table for
the Africans countries there are some 50
African countries should the
representative be South Africa which
alone represents 40 percent of African
GDP or the African economy or a giant
countries such as Nigeria that has more
than 100 million inhabitants it's up to
them to decide and determine it is not
up to us what matters is that world's
far four or five six major regions the B
as permanent members of the Security
Council people representing all of these
regions and my team my ambition is to
fast-track this one when France is in
the presidency of the g20 and the g8
might I simply add a last point here
which will be
something that the academics might wish
to mull over which is that I'm calling
for the establishment of a new
international world monetary system we
cannot go continue as we are in 1945 you
had the Marshall Plan Bretton Woods a
few kilometers away from New York and
for a year
sat down and thought about what the
world monetary order would be up until
the T at the end of the 70s where it was
the unpacking from the dollar but my
dear friends of the United States of
America dollar is no longer the world's
single currency it is a very important
currency but it is not the only currency
the one Chinese currency is an important
currency part of your savings is in
Chinese hands so we have to come up with
we have to design a new international
monetary order and decide together on
how to handle and manage interest rates
and how to regulate currency
fluctuations do you know that between
the euro and the dollar when we launched
the euro ten years ago some 10 years ago
now there was parity one dollar was won
Europe the Euro went up to 150 against
the dollar how can you expect our
companies to withstand this this is 50
percent less productivity or rather
competitiveness how could we withstand
that and in the matter in a matter of a
fortnight to three weeks the euro moved
from 150 to 133 today who can understand
that who can accept that I mean how can
we still operate on the basis of Bretton
Woods as designed 60 years ago or is it
not in our interest to stop and think
about a new international world
international monetary order that is a
fascinating discussion which I will push
forward when we're in the presidency of
the g20 and something in which I will be
talking about with president
you see new world governance new
international monetary system a new
system to regulate commodity prices and
amines and new ways of regulating the
market economy and free trade that is
what matters that is going to shape the
world in which you are going to be
living and that you will not build and
design by simply reading the books that
lay out the theories of the 19th century
but by coming up with the ideas that we
need for the 21st century the excellent
news in all of this is that today my DIF
ladies and gentlemen we have the world
is our oyster we can reinvent anything
if we have the imagination and the
cooperation that we need between Europe
in the United States of America
thank you for your attention
president Sarkozy let me just say that
we're deeply grateful for your coming to
Colombia thank you so much for big
issues of the moment and most of all for
the generosity of spirit the warmth that
you expressed Colombia reciprocate
thank you very much for coming
ladies and gentlemen we ask you to
please remain seated while the president